what i want to do in this video is
explore taking the derivatives of
exponential functions so we've already
seen that the derivative
with respect to x
of
e to the x
is equal to e to the x which is a pretty
amazing thing one of the many things
that makes e somewhat special that when
you have an exponential with your base
right over here is e the derivative of
it the slope at any point is equal to
the actual is equal to the value of that
actual function but now let's see let's
start exploring when we have other bases
can we somehow figure out what is the
derivative
what is the derivative with respect to x
when we have a to the x where a could be
any number is there some way to figure
this out and maybe using our knowledge
that the derivative of e to the x is e
to the x
well can we somehow use a little bit of
of algebra and exponent properties to
rewrite this so it does look like
something with e as a base
well you could view a
you could view a as being equal to
e
let me write it this way well all right
a is being equal to e to the natural log
of a
now i want you if this isn't is this
isn't obvious if this isn't obvious to
you i really want you to think about it
what is the natural log of a
the natural log
the natural log of a
is the power you need to raise e to to
get to a
so if you actually raise e to that power
if you raise e to the power you need to
raise e2 to get to a well then you're
just going to get to a
so really think about this if don't just
accept this
as a leap of faith it should make sense
to you and it just comes out of really
what a logarithm is
and so we can replace a with this whole
expression here we can exp if a
is the same thing as e to the natural
log of a
well then this is going to be
then
then this is going to be equal to the
derivative with respect to x of
e
e to the natural log
i keep writing l a to the natural log of
a and then we're going to raise that to
the x power we're going to raise that to
the x power
and now this just using our exponent
properties this is going to be equal to
the derivative with respect to x of
and i'll keep color coding it if i raise
something to an exponent then raise that
to an exponent that's the same thing as
raising our original base to the product
of those exponents that's just a basic
exponent properties so that's going to
be the same thing as e to the
natural log of a
natural log of a
times x power
times
x
power
and now we can use the chain rule to
evaluate this derivative
so
what we will do
is we will
first take the derivative of the outside
function so e to the natural log of a
times x with respect to the inside
function with respect to natural log of
a
times x and so this is going to be equal
to
e to the natural log of a
times x
and then we take the derivative of that
inside function with respect to x well
natural log of a might not immediately
jump out to you but that's just going to
be a number so that's just going to be
so times the derivative if it was the
derivative of 3x it would just be 3 if
it's the derivative of natural log of a
times x is just going to be natural log
natural log of a
and so this is going to give us
the natural log of a
times
e
to the natural log of a and i'm going to
write it like this natural log of a
to the x power
well we've already seen
this
let me
this right over here is just a
so it all simplifies
it all simplifies to
the natural log of a
times
times
a
to the x which is a pretty neat result
so if you're taking the derivative of e
to the x it's just going to be e to the
x if you're taking the derivative of the
natural log if you're taking the
derivative of a to the x it's just going
to be the natural log of a times a to
the x and so we can now use this result
to actually take the derivatives of of
these types of expressions with bases
other than e
so if i want to find
the derivative
with respect to x
of
8 times 3 to the x power well what's
that going to be
well that's just going to be 8 times and
then the derivative of this right over
here is going to be based on what we
just saw it's going to be the natural
log of our base
natural log of 3
times 3 to the x times 3 to the x so
it's equal to 8 natural logs of 3
times
times 3 to the x
times 3 to the x power